Nos meilleurs superordinateurs classiques gagnent en puissance,
et on devient de plus en plus performants en calcul, y compris pour simuler des systèmes.
Mais simuler la nature est un problème très difficile en général.
Je m'appelle Victoria Lipinska et aujourd'hui on va explorer l'un des algorithmes
qui pourrait rendre la simulation de la nature possible sur un ordinateur quantique.
Commençons par un exemple et considérons la caféine.
C'est une molécule simple.
Pour représenter la configuration énergétique d'une seule molécule de caféine,
on aurait besoin d'environ dix à la puissance 48 bits.
C'est dix avec 48 zéros
et c'est environ 10 % du nombre d'atomes dans la Terre.
Et en fait, ça empire encore.
Si tu as 125 orbitales et que tu veux stocker toutes les configurations possibles,
tu as besoin de plus de mémoire
dans ton ordinateur classique qu'il n'y a d'atomes dans l'univers.
C'est impossible à représenter avec des superordinateurs.
Il y a quand même de l'espoir pour les ordinateurs quantiques,
parce qu'ils sont intrinsèquement bons pour simuler la nature.
Pour une molécule de caféine, ça signifierait représenter
le système avec 160 qubits.
Ça paraît bien plus gérable.
Divers algorithmes quantiques ont été proposés pour permettre
à des ordinateurs quantiques plus petits de simuler la nature de manière heuristique.
Voici : le solveur quantique variationnel des valeurs propres, ou VQE.
Le VQE est un algorithme qui s'exécute en partie sur un ordinateur quantique
et en partie sur un ordinateur classique.
Il nous permet de trouver des valeurs qui résolvent un problème d'optimisation donné.
Le VQE est très étroitement lié à d'autres méthodes faisant intervenir
la variation de paramètres, comme l'algorithme d'optimisation approximative quantique.
Identifier les applications du VQE dans ton secteur ou ta recherche
relève d'une certaine forme d'art, mais il existe des lignes directrices générales.
En général, le VQE s'applique aux problèmes qui peuvent être formulés
comme un problème d'optimisation à variables continues.
C'est le cas, par exemple, dans une grande partie de la chimie quantique.
Très souvent, en chimie, on s'intéresse à l'état fondamental.
L'état fondamental est l'état d'énergie minimale du système.
Pour trouver l'énergie de l'état fondamental, le VQE explore
l'énergie pour différentes configurations du système
et cherche la configuration d'énergie la plus basse.
À haut niveau, le VQE prend en entrée une description du système quantique
et cherche l'énergie la plus basse.
Il fait ça en faisant varier la configuration du système.
Pour commencer, on doit fournir une description appropriée du système
que l'ordinateur quantique peut comprendre, ainsi qu'un ensemble de paramètres le décrivant,
qui seront optimisés.
La partie quantique de
l'algorithme prépare le système dans un état
décrit par un ensemble de paramètres donné et calcule l'énergie.
Tandis que la partie classique est responsable
de l'optimisation de ces paramètres à chaque étape.
Ce processus quantique-classique est répété
jusqu'à ce qu'on atteigne l'énergie la plus basse.
Regardons maintenant de plus près ce qui se passe sous le capot.
La configuration énergétique est généralement décrite dans le Hamiltonien
et c'est généralement une très grande matrice.
En algèbre, pour trouver la plus petite valeur propre de la matrice
correspondant à l'énergie la plus basse du système,
on effectuerait simplement une décomposition en valeurs singulières.
Cependant, les matrices qu'on va examiner sont exponentiellement grandes
et c'est un problème exponentiellement difficile à résoudre algébriquement.
Ce Hamiltonien doit être représenté sous une forme
que l'ordinateur quantique peut comprendre.
Donc traduit du langage de la chimie vers le langage du calcul quantique.
Pas d'inquiétude pour les détails toutefois.
Il existe finalement des façons programmables de traduire le Hamiltonien tel qu'il apparaît
généralement en chimie vers un Hamiltonien compréhensible pour un ordinateur quantique.
On entre ensuite ce
Hamiltonien avec le circuit, qu'on appelle une forme variationnelle.
Choisir une forme variationnelle relève d'une certaine forme d'art.
Encore une fois,
elle représente notre meilleure hypothèse sur ce que pourrait être l'état quantique du système.
Ce circuit variationnel est paramétré par un ensemble de paramètres thêta,
et on fournit également un choix initial de ces paramètres.
Sur cette base, la partie quantique du VQE :
prépare l'état de référence, par exemple l'état zéro ;
utilise un circuit quantique paramétré, la forme variationnelle, pour préparer un état quantique
avec une estimation initiale des paramètres sur l'ordinateur quantique ; et estime
l'énergie correspondant à l'état évalué à travers le Hamiltonien.
Cette estimation d'énergie est ensuite transmise
à l'optimiseur classique, qui trouve un nouvel ensemble de paramètres.
Les paramètres retournent vers le solveur quantique,
et tout le processus est répété.
L'ordinateur quantique trouve une nouvelle estimation d'énergie, et
l'optimiseur classique trouve un nouvel ensemble de paramètres, et ainsi de suite.
On répète ce processus jusqu'à ce que la solution converge.
C'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce que la différence entre les résultats d'une étape à l'autre soit suffisamment petite
pour nos besoins.
À la fin, l'algorithme retourne cette énergie minimisée.
OK, c'est super.
Mais tu te demandes peut-être comment on sait que ça fonctionne vraiment
et qu'on ne va pas trouver accidentellement une énergie inférieure à ce qu'on cherche ?
C'est une excellente question.
Il s'avère qu'on ne peut jamais estimer une énergie inférieure.
C'est grâce à ce qu'on appelle un principe variationnel.
Le principe variationnel stipule que la plus grande borne inférieure
sur l'énergie du système est toujours son
énergie la plus basse correspondant à cet état fondamental.
Ça signifie que l'énergie évaluée pour n'importe quel autre état de ce système
sera toujours supérieure à l'énergie la plus basse.
Par conséquent, avec le VQE on ne peut jamais obtenir quelque chose
d'inférieur à l'énergie de l'état fondamental.
Cependant, on peut effectivement converger vers quelque chose
de supérieur au minimum qu'on cherche.
C'est ce qu'on appelle souvent une solution métastable
et c'est un défi que les chercheurs tentent de résoudre au quotidien.
Le VQE est utile parce qu'il utilise des circuits moins profonds
comparé à d'autres protocoles qui permettent d'estimer l'énergie de l'état fondamental.
Ça le rend adapté au matériel quantique à court terme.
Dans cette vidéo, on a eu un aperçu de ce que le VQE peut faire et comment il est construit.
Mais je t'encourage à explorer Qiskit dans ce contexte.
Même si on est encore au début de notre voyage quantique,
tu pourrais déjà le trouver utile pour les problèmes que tu essaies de résoudre.
Je m'appelle Victoria Lipinska et c'était une présentation
de l'algorithme du solveur quantique variationnel des valeurs propres.